from hot sauce to ranch we want to try
all the exclusive sauces at fast food
restaurants in the u.s the uk and japan
this is sauce talk
[Music]
exclusive sauces it's sauce talk time
sauce talk
we have sweet and sour sauce they gave
me
hot mustard
this would be honey mustard you guys
have hot mustard i know you don't have
honey mustard of course ranch
uh ooh
spicy buffalo
now these might be promotions because of
that
singing group bts
but we have right now a
cajun sauce and a sweet chili sauce this
sauce is
fantastic this is the sauce this has to
stay in the morning so these two are new
ones
this one right here is
soy sauce based sauce
man this is fantastic good job
very good taste
so this one right here is called
louisiana jostos oh
it does look like a very spicy one
[Music]
this is not spicy at all
[Music]
i think that these sauces are also
specific only to the u.s and not the uk
the kfc finger looking good sauce
see that
we also have the summertime barbecue
sauce
uh honey mustard
and of course buttermilk ranch
there are a few sources which are
exclusive to the uk for example we have
this spicy supercharger dip which is
kind of like a spicy mayo type thing we
have some sweet chili sauce garlic
mayonnaise another really good option
garlic mayo on chips is just fantastic
why don't we have those sauces here
oh man i want those so this deep pack it
comes with this fries and also
these three
dipping sauces and now for the quickest
sauce talk ever kfc sauce
if you need something to dip your veggie
bites or anything else into then we have
a couple of exclusive sauce options as
well we'll start with this one which is
a garlic mayo and then our other
exclusive sauce is this one which is a
part of heinz sweet chili we love sweet
chilli sauce here in the uk i don't know
why but it's just offered by like a lot
of big fast food chains i got a whole
bag here
dipping sauces
buttermilk ranch
ooh
creamy sriracha
side of sauce
something called the hot chili seasoning
now the default dipping sauce that will
come with your pizzas is this garlic and
herb dip in the uk but there are also a
couple of sources which are exclusive to
the uk these include a little pot of
frank's red hot sauce and we can also
get a honey mustard
the dominoes in the u.s has their own
exclusive sauces
this kicker hot sauce
the sweet mango habanero sauce this one
is really good
uh ranch you guys don't have ranch
thought you did guess not blue cheese
dressing
and of course marinara sauce
so here is extra sauces so if you want
you can get green chili sauce or
honey syrup so the wing street wings you
can get a pizza hut also come in
exclusive flavors you can't get in japan
here are all the sauces
spicy garlic is really good joe's sauce
seal of approval teriyaki this seems
like a no-brainer but we're not gonna
leave it to chance
no
that's not correct this is terrible
doesn't pass garlic parmesan oh look
there's like parmesan like on top of it
[Laughter]
that might be the best one
lemon pepper dry rub why do i have to
apply it
yeah i'm not into that man i don't get
it i don't know what drake's going on
about man lemon pepper's not very good
crucify me internet i don't like lemon
pepper dry rub wings should i i think
maybe i should be rubbing it that's what
i'm doing wrong
is that too much
whoops yeah you're right too much
that's good also sauces real quick we
got blue cheese we got ranch you can
also get exclusive sauces on the side
for instance blue cheese
get yourself some ranch uh a cup of
marinara and the buffalo sauces of
various temperatures honey barbecue
sauce
we've got
a tartar sauce
the creole
cocktail sauce
creole is a type of cuisine in louisiana
blackened ranch was this supposed to be
for the blackened chicken do you think
and of course we have regular buttermilk
ranch
well we already know what ranch is
ranching
black and ranch
oh that's way better
the sweet heat
had this earlier with the tenders can
confirm fantastic sauce wild honey
mustard
and the
bayou buffalo sauce in the uk we have
the following exclusive sauces
we have this voodoo sweet chili sauce
which could be quite similar to the u.s
sweet heat source
then we have a garlic mayo
as well as a mango habanero sauce which
sounds really good it's not exclusive
but shout out to the mardi gras mustard
because this stuff slaps
now it's not exactly an exclusive but
it's worth a shout out musician megan
the stallion recently launched a collab
with popeyes and released the hottie
sauce you can get as a side for dip or
pre-edit your chicken sandwich or if
you're in the uk you can dip a hot wing
into the hottie sauce and have a hot
wing summer
she's also becoming a popeye's
franchisee as she is opening her own
popeyes soon and then underneath this it
says need some wap content here open to
ideas i'm assuming she's the one who did
the song w.a.p i don't know who this
person is i've never heard wap i just
know it as a reference on the internet
and i am going to bask
in the glory that only some of my age
can of not having any idea what a
popular thing is ah
i couldn't get any of them on the side
but we have exclusive sauces here at the
subway in the u.s we can get a red wine
vinegar a yellow mustard a creamy
sriracha
a buffalo sauce of course we also have
ranch chipotle southwest marinara sauce
sweet onion sauce and mvp parmesan
the most valuable parmesan apparently
we have four sources that you won't find
in the us and they are as follows we
have a buffalo sauce sriracha mayo which
in my opinion is one of if not the best
condiment then we have a sweet chili
sauce and finally we have an asian
ginger chili sauce creamy sriracha ranch
i'm very fascinated with this a
pineapple barbecue i've never tried the
asian ginger chili sauce before oh i
like it
yeah that's good awesome
definitely hot you can see like chili
flakes kind of floating around in there
and that's not a red herring pineapple
barbecue
pineapple barbecue
that's fantastic barbecue sauce this
tastes a lot like like a sweeter creamer
version of mcdonald's like standard
barbecue sauce
if they sold this in retail i would
absolutely buy it that's very good wow
i love you jolly bean okay
only one option in the uk that you won't
be able to find in the us and that is hp
source i won't go into too much detail
in case joe accuses me of brits blaming
again but for those who don't know hp
source is like the only customization in
the us that you can't get in the uk is
actually something that everyone in the
united states knows exactly what i'm
talking about and that is a one steak
sauce
it looks a lot like the hp brown sauce
but it is not it doesn't taste anything
like it it is
the most popular
steak zones
he won it's how stage
is done
i don't know if it even exists outside
of the us
so for exclusive wing flavors you can
get these two the bayou barbecue and the
lemon hot so fun fact about me i've
never actually had raj before this is
not a common dressing in the uk
it's just not really on menus we prefer
like a garlic mayonnaise or a ketchup
so i'm about to try it my first ever
brunch see how it goes
hmm
okay okay
i don't know if wingstop branch differs
to the classic you might find in the
states but it's nice if you want like a
kind of
cooling thing
with a similar effect to mayo in that
regard but like a little bit more tang
but more seasoning
yeah you guys are doing it well
this is 10 chicken wings of varying
spice levels the idea i guess is that
you order a plate of these for yourself
and your friends you will pick one or
two and the loser gets blasted with some
extra hot sauce now obviously we have to
try this ourselves so myself and our
camera person laura are going to give
this a go and see who loses are we doing
this now i think we are all right
okay that one looks yeah you're going
dangerous i'm going for like a
menacingly red one yes you are i'm going
for the less menacing looking one
hopefully it's a red herring with dennis
to deceive you cheers cheers
absolutely fine
yeah it's spicy it's not like blowing my
head off i feel like mine's maybe
hot but if that's extra hot then i'm
like very underwhelmed slight
anti-climax i think laura maybe just got
like a medium or a plain one because she
was not faced at all i think maybe i got
like hot if that was extra hot i'm very
disappointed all i say a little cocky
there buddy so i got myself a bottle of
the nando's peripery xx hot sauce and i
too want to try
the spiciest level that they offer okay
that might have been too much
that's extra hot huh no i'm very strong
i like the flavor a lot on that but wait
definitely manageable yeah i mean like i
love the flavor of all this stuff this
is not that hard
[Music]
now for those of you who think i got off
lightly and actually want to see me in
pain you're in luck because in the uk we
have an exclusive spice level that goes
above extra hot here we have three
chicken wings coated in vusa xx sauce
which is one level above extra hot on
the nando's periometer now these already
looked hotter than anything that was in
the roulette box there's lots of chilli
flakes on them that are visible and it's
just that kind of like alarming red
color that if you see a snake that color
you're supposed to run away from
snakes in general some sticks are
friendly
grass snakes grass snakes are cool and
of course because i hate myself i'm
going to try one of these they didn't
give us gloves like they did in the
wingstop episode which i guess is a good
sign i'm not great with spice so let's
see how this goes
is that the slow burn
it's a really slow bum i'm not really
getting much from this i'll be honest
maybe if i just rub my eyes i'm not
really getting it that's disappointing
i like to say i'm not good with spice
but i'm paddling that with these nando's
come on it would have made for better
content if you made me cry guys so it's
about the same as what i got from there
y'all tried your really hot wings right
well i just wanted a taste of the the
hot sauce that they provided us with
here if i can get it open at
any point in my life
nando's peri-peri sauce hot gluten free
no
it's from the camera
[Laughter]
i should get an oscar
it was a little hot
but it wasn't like too hot that i'm
dying it's kind of spicy but this
already has i did that to trick you
did you see how it became a double agent
wow
i actually did have a reaction no it's
really sweet it just hits you in the
throat it's like
at the other end of the heat scale from
vusa we have one more exclusive based
which is the peri peritamer this is
described as mild and sweet and it's
just for people who don't really like
spice
of course we're adding white and red
sauces right okay the white sauce pouch
one of these is roughly 330 calories 37
grams of fat 6 grams of saturated fat
420 milligrams of sodium for 20
and 2 grams of carbs
see this guy right here each package of
their hot sauce adds only 7 calories but
89 milligrams of sodium let's talk about
the red source now according to the
halal guys website their red source
ranges from between 100 000 to 130 000
on the scoville scale to put that in
perspective sriracha is somewhere around
2500 on the same scale and the infamous
hot ones de bomb source is around 135
000 so pretty close to this a lot of
guys have something called the hot sauce
challenge what it is is a small platter
with 20 lines of their hot sauce
and you got to be able to eat the whole
thing
in 10 minutes
with no assistance of any beverages
not only during while you're eating it
but also five minutes after sorry what
are we doing
so one
two
it sounds like this where you're like i
should have a will written just in case
that's for
oh my god if i don't make it out of this
uh someone tell my cat that i love him
20 houses
this is such a bad idea
right yeah
all right
[Music]
oh my god
this stuff is really hot
oh man i'm like getting like a metallic
taste in my mouth like my mouth might be
bleeding
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
okay yep
that's immediately spicy no slow down
here
oh god
this was a mistake
that's like really good dude
oh
god how long has it been
one minute now
okay
okay i never managed this
horrible
the eyes are watering the throat is
hurting
hmm
this is really hot my tongue
back in the mouth everything
[Music]
no way i'm lasting five minutes i'm
breaking early oh god
i throw in the towel i can't do it
yeah holy sh
how long was that
three minutes and ten seconds
see you now knows
that is spice if you advertise something
is spicy
at least deliver and that's what our
guys have done
[Music]
you